it's wonderful to be with you all and
back at Yale we've got our larger group
this time but I having read some of the
Seavey's of people I obviously in the
presence of an immense amount of
accumulated experience as well as
intelligence so it's a real honor and
pleasure for me to ticket to come and
let you and take these classes over the
coming weeks miss Martha said to me I'm
now dressed like a member of the Yale
faculty I haven't yet acquired the
mental skills to go with it but you know
we're working on that and see one of the
things when I was just thinking of the
lot last bit you were saying they're
about Gregory Clark and wealth not
bringing happiness he thinks that we
were whereas the hunter-gatherers were
as happy as we are mmm sure about that
reminds me of that this friend of mine
who's really really wealthy guy
philanthropist and he went as part of
his philanthropic judy's went and
lectured in in the third world and he
was lecturing a class a bit like this of
students obviously very poor and gave
him this line about how well the read
didn't make for happiness and they
should understand that and he could
speak like that because there's a
wealthy person once the students came
out to afters and said look your wealth
is obviously distressing you a lord yeah
if you were to give me your wealth you
know I would relieve you of the burden
of that distress so I'm a little
surprisingly enough he didn't take him
up on the offer so I'm not sure about
that but now what what I wanted to do is
to give an introduction as to really in
a sense why this course I mean we know
that faith contrary to what people
believed some time ago faith is growing
not diminishing so that whole sweep of
European and Western intellectual
thought that said as we develop so
faithful will fall away and we will be
liberated from the dogmas and mysticism
and foolishness of religion we know that
that is not in fact happened faith is
growing not diminishing and we also know
that globalization is here with us is an
unstoppable force and is in a sense
defining the world which we live both in
terms of economy and lifestyle and
communication and so on the question is
why put them together really I mean why
say let's study faith and globalization
okay both are clearly acknowledged
aspects of the world today but but why
do we examine them together and the
reason for that and this partnership
with Yale and now with other
universities in the world arose out of
my foundation which is about religious
interfaith and how we get better
understanding between people of
different faiths in the world and the
reason I put these two subjects together
is that I think the key aspect or the
key characteristic of globalization is
that it is pushing the world together I
mean I often say to people when I was
growing up as a young boy in the
northeast of England a place called
Durham I actually remember the day I met
my first non-white person you know I was
12 years old I lived in a very very
restricted little environment my
community was my community the lady they
used to come in and help my mum with
various things in the house had never
been outside county durham in all the 60
years of her life and i think when she
died she probably never been outside
this little space right that was the
world that i grew up in and i never
really actually one of my best friends
when I was growing up was in fact Jewish
I never even asked him about his afraid
I'd just assumed everyone was Christian
so that's the world but that used to be
my children today have at least three
different faiths amongst their friends
my little ten-year-old never mind my old
ones who are obviously in the workplace
in London will
lots of different people from lots of
different phase so globalization is
pushing the world together and the
question really is because religion is
growing and I think growing us I'll come
to in a moment for the reasons in some
sense connected with globalization
actually as globalization pushes people
together will religious faith become a
force that pulls them apart again that's
why the two things coming together are
so important and if we understand the
role of faith in the world if we
understand different faiths and cultures
better then we have a chance both to
make faith a source of progress in an
era of globalization since as I will say
in a moment I think that faith can play
a very positive role in the era of
globalization and we are more likely to
reduce the possibility of faith be used
as a source of conflict so this
relationship between faith and
globalization is I think at the heart of
what makes the world tick today and as I
often say to people i think the 20th
century was essentially dominated by
fundamental political ideology but i
don't think the 21st century will be
dominated in the same way by political
ideology i think it could well be
dominated however by religious or
cultural ideology now you can work out
sometimes in this great debate about
what's really religion what's really
politics but you know what I mean in
other words a traditional battle between
left and right over the market
capitalism versus socialism I think is
gonna that battle will still remain but
within far narrower parameters however
the prospects of different cultural
religious forces pulling the world apart
is very much present and with us and an
active risk in our world today
and I think when we come to look at the
issue of faith faith really operates in
two different aspects for people one is
faith as my identity right I am a
Christian and that is not necessarily in
opposition to you as a Muslim or a Hindu
or a Jew or whatever but it is faith as
as an identity with a set of doctrines
with a set of religious instructions
that go with it guitar applicable simply
to that faith so that is faith as I will
call it faith as identity but faith also
plays a different role which is faith as
values faith as the values that motivate
people that give them purpose in their
lives that try and make them better
people that give rise to the human
flourishing that miroslav just been
talking about so faith is about what you
are but it's also about what you do what
it means in your life and faith of
course makes certain truth claims each
faith will make its own truth claims and
to that extent of course faith is
exclusive since the truth claims are
different in all the major different
faiths but you can have faith that makes
truth claims that are exclusive to that
faith without necessarily using those
truth claims as a badge of opposition or
maybe exclusivism in other words you
start to define yourself as with your
truth claims in opposition to those who
have different truth claims so what I
mean by that is that faith necessarily
has the characteristic if you are of
someone of a faith I'm a Muslim I have a
view about the importance of the Koran
which a Christian or a Jew does not
write that is a truth claim about the
Koran that is distinct
in one sense it is obviously exclusive
but it does not necessarily follow from
that that you then regard yourself as in
opposition to others so I think a low
faith is necessarily a badge of identity
it and in one sense exclusive identity
it doesn't necessarily mean that that
identity has to be in opposition to
others but there is a risk of that let
us say so faith has this notion of
identity in it but it also has this
notion of values and as we'll see in a
moment when it comes to values then
sometimes faith can have a commonality
which in terms of identity it plainly
doesn't the other thing about faith very
obviously is faith in today's world is
seen as a force for conflict as a source
of division but it can also be a force
for good that's a very statement of the
obvious but those two aspects of faith
are very dramatically there with us and
indeed i would say that just at the same
time as a faith itself and people of
faith are growing the resource of
probably a reaction against that in fact
you can see this a secular reaction
against that from people who say hey you
guys are actually the problem in the
world so I'm against faith I mean I
rather curiously for me as a Christian I
was brought up my daddy was in fact and
these in fact a militant atheist and you
know his view of it is you know look
back in history all these various crazy
people that cause nothing baha so I'm a
rationalist I'm a humanist and don't
tell me about faith and I want to know
about it it's all that does is look at
the wars in the world that have been
caused by now I then have a big debate
about it and say actually look at what
political ideology did in the 20th
century you know honor you can have this
debate but you faith
is seen by people today as with this
contradictory aspect or than one hand it
can be a source when you see the work
that relief organizations islamic relief
to you is relieved for the christian
relief organizations do in some of the
poorest parts of the world it's a
magnificent demonstration of faith and
then you have the fundamentalism more or
the extremism which is obviously faith
in its worst aspect so that it was what
is happening in the world of faith those
are maybe the characteristics that that
we could identify today with faith in
his place in the modern world occupying
a larger place in our lives i think then
maybe 15 20 years ago and the
interaction with globalization is
absolutely central because of the way
the globalization operates so let's just
examine globalization for a minute this
globalization this sort of g-force I
think when you analyze globalization
there are certain things that are
necessary to say about it sometimes
there's a the idea is the globalization
is essentially a policy of governments I
don't actually think this is true i mean
been in government I think globalization
is driven essentially by people so
people getting access to technology and
to travel and to mass communication this
is what is fueling globalization and
frankly there's not much governments can
do to stop that happening because the
technology and the science is driving
people to be able to do far more across
national boundaries than they ever did
before so globalization to my mind is
our force driven by people and it is by
the way
positive than many of its aspects I mean
where I disagree with some of what is
written and even you know that you've
been reading for this lecture on
globalization is if you take a country
like China and you see that that the
fact that they've lifted hundreds and
millions of people out of poverty in the
last 20 years that was as a direct
consequence of the opening up policy
China hadn't opened up China would not
be in the situation it is today so when
that decision was taken in the 1970s to
open China up the result of it was that
they were able then dramatically to
increase the living standards of their
people same with India when actually the
present indian prime minister manmohan
singh was finance minister back in the
early 90s and began the process of
liberalizing the indian economy not
vastly far but further than it had been
before it definitely brought prosperity
for people whatever the problems of the
European Union right now the fact is the
single market you can see this very
clearly has actually engineered huge
amount of growth and opportunity for
people I would even say in respect of
Africa that though you can make
arguments about how globalization has
exploited Africa I actually think that
it's less globalization that is
exploited Africa than the combination of
globalization and bad governance and
actually I think that if you bring
decent governance to Africa combined
with globalization it would in fact open
up opportunity there as well but that's
a debate you can have but the point is I
think what is virtually unbeatable is
the globalization at least in certain
aspects has had a positive impact but
there are negatives and there are
negatives because as miroslav was just
saying in areas like the environment
globalization can be blind to the
consequences of its force there are
negatives because people become aware of
difference far more today one of the
things that this era of technology and
mass communication does is make people
aware of the injustice 'as and the
inequalities if you look at the
financial crisis you can argue about the
causes of it but you can say perfectly
justifiably that one element of it at
least was a failure to regulate
sufficiently the process of
globalization in the financial sector or
at least to understand it and to
supervise it adequately and the case
that I would make is that globalization
with its positive and its negative
aspects when you then take a step back
and say well how do you bring out the
positive and diminish the negative I
think you necessarily reach for a set of
values to do that so the issue then
becomes not whether you try and stop
globalization but how do you shape it
how do you spread its benefits how in
other words do you put some human
decision-making into what is otherwise
potentially an impersonal economic
social force that carries people
wherever it will carry them so
most people I think today even if
they're on the side of globalization is
a positive recognize that globalization
also needs to be informed by certain
values not just for it to be fair
incidentally hello it being fair is
important but I would even argue for it
to work so I think globalization without
rules without values probably is not
merely a globalization that will lead to
an acute sense of injustice and those
that are left behind by it but also it
will smile up it will fail to function
effectively at certain critical
challenge points so what we have is a
situation where globalization as a force
unsettled because it moves fast and
we're seeming indifference to its effect
on people but it is nonetheless
something that is a force that is driven
by people and is opening the world up
and is going to carry on so the question
then becomes well given that that is how
globalization is can faith provide the
values that shape this globalization in
a in a benign way and the truth is it
can regard because it can if faith is
about values and values that as it where
people can share to an extent at least
in common across faiths and so come to
some sort of agreement about the moral
imperatives that should govern our
attitude to globalization and faith
can't provide batch
unifying and healthy role if faith in
fact operates as a counter force to
globalization and actually ends up with
people believing that as globalization
pushes people together they've actually
got to stand up for their religion as a
badge of identity in resisting this
force and denying it now that reaction
against globalization happening in the
world of faith is very clear you can see
it here in America you can see it in
virtually any European country you care
to mention at the moment I mean it pops
up in immigration debate very noticeably
it pops up in debates over as we can see
the whole Ground Zero issue in New York
in France whether it's just been a major
debate and actually virtually anywhere
in Europe today you could fight and
possibly send sadly even winner an
election pretty much honor you know our
luck way of life is under threat from
then pick your class of people that you
want to identify as the other and that
is where you know the two aspects of
faith faith as identity faith as values
are very very important to get to get
right because when we talk about faith
growing in the world faith is growing
the numbers of people connected to the
faith community are growing but
some of those are becoming more what I
would call out could be misconstrued
this as a term but of what I would call
more fundamentalist and they tend often
to see globalization as a threat to
their faith and in a sense their
fundamentalism becomes a reaction to
that globalization and so for example
one of the interesting aspects of
globalization and of modern business is
if you want to if you want to succeed in
modern business today you have to
develop your human capital and an era of
globalization discrimination on the
grounds of your gender or your faith or
your race actually becomes an inhibiting
factor for the success of your business
so the most successful businesses I know
any of them operating at a global level
are operating on the basis of equality
not not because they think it's as some
simply some great moral cause but
because actually otherwise you're
wasting the human capital you're not
accessing the potential of your your
workforce now sometimes the very
fundamentalism that comes into religious
faith is precisely set in opposition to
that whole notion of people coming
together of equality and there is a
battle within each major religion at the
moment I mean we think about it very
much in terms of Islam but actually the
same battles going on in Christianity
most of my time I spend an hour in the
Middle East in my office in Jerusalem
which is just on the borderline between
East and West Jerusalem you look out of
one window and you will see very
Orthodox Jews in the very Orthodox
costume you
look out of the other side literally the
other side of the room facing the
eastern direction and you will tend to
see women and indeed men in very
traditional Islamic dress so this idea
if you like of religion growing and by
the way both groups will tell you in
Jerusalem those who were brought up Jews
or Muslims will tell you that Jerusalem
is an infinitely more religious and
fundamentally so more religious place
than it was 15 or 20 years ago which is
interesting in itself that
fundamentalism is growing right now at
the other side part of what is driving
the growth in numbers of people of
religious faith is actually a search for
spirituality which is slightly different
so what is interesting in the UK
whenever we pull people on religion is
the numbers of people who go to church
now in the UK and I mean I think in
America the figures still over fifty
percent isn't it you go to judge will go
to some form of worship every week in
the UK I think it's down about ten
percent you go to church so it's not a
great deal but you post the question do
you believe in God the figures go right
up back over sixty seventy percent and
more so I think the other thing that's
happening in the growth of religion he's
actually a search for spirituality which
is precisely not a reaction against
globalization but a desire to put
alongside globalization some sense that
life is more than simply about material
circumstances or material well so these
two things together are creating a
greater
movement towards religious faith and
what we're finding is an analysis of
faith today is part theology part
sociology part politics and possibly
even part economics now given therefore
the globalization as is positive isn't
its negatives that faith has these also
these two aspects to its development
today how then when we link the two
together do we get faith to play a
positive part and i would offer these
points very briefly to you I'd have made
seven of them because that's kind of
biblical now I just don't mean that how
do we make faith positive in this era of
globalization one whilst each faith has
its exclusive truth claims we define a
space of common values and that is
actually very easy to do because the
basic principle do unto others as you
would have them do unto you is actually
found in all of the key religious face
actually when I was in China recently
Confucius said the same so it's a very
very universal principle and there are
common aims of social justice a belief
in enhancing the opportunities of others
which face can share in common so even
though they have their exclusive truth
claims we should try to develop between
the face this common space of shared
values in fact one of the things that
you'll see in the course of this is
there is a program actually specifically
between Muslims and Christians called
the common word which is is
actually to try and provide the
theological basis for such a common
space at least between Christians and
Muslims but frankly could apply to Jews
Hindus Buddhists Sikhs and so on the
second thing is to have a debate arising
out of which it would be good to get
clarity about what is the proper public
role of faith groups in in the political
life of a country now my view in the end
is that the proper place is a right to
speak and to be heard but not a right to
dictate now I just offer you that but
it's you know other people who have
different views but I think you know I
face this as prime minister in the UK
because I'm someone of religious faith
and I actually I'm a Catholic but I took
positions on certain issues gay rights
probably being the most obvious of them
which were contrary to that of the
Catholic Church one of the hardest
things I had to do when it just shows
you whether how this is this is a very
very difficult area where there were
adoption agencies for children from very
disadvantaged backgrounds in the UK
right so there are agencies and many of
them are religious in nature who help
children from abused abusive backgrounds
they take them in and they find parents
to adopt them so it's a it's a great
service is very very important service
the Catholic adoption agencies when the
changes the law came in so that there is
a quality between gay people non gay
people Catholic adoption agency said
look we we're not going to adopt for gay
parents would that's not our but it's
not going to do it
and it was just one of these interesting
things because I'd always taken a very
pro-gay rights position on the other
hand people were asking me to shut down
these Catholic adoption agencies who
were doing most fantastic work but they
didn't share that position on gay so you
know now in the end we found and i found
a way through it but it was one of these
situations where you got attack from all
sides some people didn't like your
position or gay rights some people said
well if that's your position then you
should be forcing the Catholics to do it
and I want to try and find a way through
it now the Catholic Church throughout
that you know they could get pretty
heavy you know the notices were going up
in the church and my attitude was very
very simple with them which is you've
got an absolute right to speak and to be
heard but I am the Prime Minister so you
know not and that instant it was not
because I want to say my position is
definitively right in your positions
wrong it could have been the other way
around but in the end I wanted to define
that that role in the faith group in the
public space because of course then you
get a whole lot of other people with
other positions and then it can become
quite difficult to cut them but I use
that as an illustration of the fact that
the second point that I would make is
faith to be a positive you we need to we
need to have that debate and define it
and try and get as much clarity as we
can about what is the proper role of
faith in the public space the third
thing is something very basic which is
what my faith foundation tries to do
with its schools program but we should
just we should actually have active
programs as society doesn't matter we
run by government incidentally to
understand the other you know when I was
here a few days ago and someone asked me
about burning the koran I said actually
why don't you read it because it's
interesting to read is soon so it's
fascinating for me is a Christian to
study the Koran and you know I now when
I read about other religions it actually
helps in
form enormously my view of of other
cultures so for example I she don't
think you can you can understand China
today unless you know you don't simply
read the political speeches but you
actually go back and read those
philosophers that are very much given
rise to the Chinese personality and the
character and the way people think so
programs of understanding is the third
thing that the faith community needs and
it they need to be involved in that
without feeling it threatens their own
faith believe it or not in our
experience the more people know about
another faith it doesn't actually
dislodge their own faith but it it
enriches it certainly I've found that
and I think others can too the fourth
thing is we store those people of faith
if we believe in God acknowledge our
limitations of God's purpose and will
and knowledge in other words one is a
rabbi he said to me who's very much
involved in the Interfaith and you know
the toughest question you always get
asked is is this and I remember doing a
panel at Davos in the international
forum and I had four clerics and me
right so felt very holy there was
there's a rabbis a rabbi in the Grand
Mufti Bosnia and there was chief rabbi
the Grand Mufti of Bosnia there was a
Buddhist and then there was a cleric
actually from from America an
evangelical and we had an interfaith
discussion it was a great discussion and
in the end of it I'm feeling be just
being a little too been getting on with
each other all too well really I said to
them so tell me do you believe that your
faith is the only true path to salvation
and it was a fascinating thing you see
because the audience actually quite
wanted to know the answer to that the
clerics of course all started behaving
like politicians which really was
probably sensible in the air and it is
difficult this very very difficult
because you know that if you are a
Christian you have certain beliefs right
and they are different from the other
person's beliefs is it you can't expel
that from your mind but if you at least
acknowledge the limitations of your
knowledge of God's will it gives you
that little bit of humility that can
lead to a lot of respect for others
despite the difference the fourth fifth
thing rather is if you want faith to be
a positive then we have to use the
ability of faith to mobilize human
activity for purposes that are for the
human good in other words one of the
things my foundation does is about the
anti malaria campaign of the United
Nations and we try to get people
different faiths involved both in
spreading the word in the developed
nations about how important this is and
then out in Africa getting the
particularly the temp the churches and
the mosques as distribution centers the
bed nets for malaria and so on but the
point is what you're trying to do is to
emphasize and augment that dimension of
faith that is about the good of humanity
and one of the things that faith groups
habits is incredible mobilizing power
well we should use that mobilizing power
for the common good that is one major
way that face because sometimes face
find it easier to work together on
programs of action than they do to
discuss issues of theology
his programs of action can unite issues
of theology can often divide the six the
thing is that and this is why the
academic aspect of this is so important
and why it's not just Yale that has this
course today we've now got roughly I
think eight or nine universities will
expand it to about twelve or fifteen
taking this course one of the things we
want to do in the course of all of this
is to to get people to recognize the
religion and religious thought itself is
evolving religions actually don't stand
still in fact and an analysis and
understanding an examination of that
process I think is also of benefit in
making faith as a whole a force for good
because then rather than seeing religion
as a static set of institutions beliefs
and practices we actually comprehend
that there is an evolutionary process
within religious thought that is
continuing all the time and that
evolutionary process of you read Karen
Armstrong's book the great
transformation you see it tracked from
faerie early times and as you were
saying about the actual period the truth
is there was a moment in which suddenly
religion became rather than a an often
violent and mercurial and inconsistent
God whose views nonetheless had to be
obeyed suddenly you got that evolution
to an ethical dimension to religion that
was actually about a god that was
rational and trying to shape the world
in a way that was good so you know it's
foolish for us sitting here in the 21st
century not to notice and to track and
to understand that process of evolution
and the final point the seventh is this
I think faith is more likely to be a
positive if we don't confuse values with
policies I mean I think this is very
very difficult because it's difficult
particularly in the context of some of
the things we've read verte for this
week you see I used to in the g8 in
glynnie gel's in 2005 I put Africa on
the agenda of the g8 and we agreed this
program of aid and debt relief and so on
and I saw the it was actually remarkable
for many things not least when you're
very very busy as Prime Minister right
people come in and out at Downing Street
the whole time and you don't always get
a proper track of your program for the
day okay and one of the things that was
organized unbeknownst to me was because
the Church of England allow women
priests right was there was a a march of
women priests on on Downing Street and
it all turned up in Downing Street about
200 of them dressed with clerical
collars and I I thought this was a skit
or joke or something so I actually
didn't so I'm going out to greet the
lighting yes sir come on so where are
you from they say we mean where we from
where the point I said no no but
seriously who are you with bracelet 200
of them very formidable incidentally not
to be messed around with anyway so you
know I was pretty much polishing shoes
by the end of that so but the the point
is this when i SAT them down we were
able to agree on debt relief we couldn't
agree on free trade right they thought
free traders a capitalist conspiracy hi
and I was saying to know I don't agree
with that I'm afraid I actually think
African countries need they need to
break down trade barriers between
themselves first of all and then
actually they need to participate we can
give them access to European markets but
actually it's better for them if they're
participating in the global trading
framework and the point I'm making is
there
faith it will be more of a positive if
we understand what faith can do and what
it can't what faith can do is give you
values by which you approach decision
making unfortunately it can't tell you
what the right decision is that's that's
policy that's got to be also decided by
a rational debate and believe it or not
people can come to different points of
views to what that means so you know I
was used to say people used to say to me
this faith play a part in your role as
Prime Minister Isis I of course of your
person and faith that plays a part but
you know I can't go into a corner and
pray to God and say what is you know
what should the minimum wage be it next
year if you didn't tell you the answer
the great vida bitties isn't so that's
got to be worked out differently so what
that also means is that that position of
faith in this political space you know
again has to be defined carefully
otherwise it ceases to be a force for
good and becomes and actually a force
and a source of division so that is
those are the basic principles which I
think if we apply to the interaction of
faith with globalization can lead to the
positive outcomes the final point I
conclude on is this that I think um
one thing we want to do out of this this
has been running now too this is the
third year and as I say we're now
extending this to other universities who
are doing their different notions of
this so we've just conclude an agreement
with Peking University with monterey
tech in mexico national university of
singapore mcgill durham university we
will look at we've got two or three
universities in the Middle East we are
analyzing now as as possible partners
what we want to do in the end is to get
to this concept of you know religion in
its place in the modern world faith and
globalization as a discipline of an
academic nature where we are examining
these key issues doing research on it
and publishing material on it because
this issue now with the greatest
deference to the divinity part
department one of the reasons we did
this miroslav and I first in the way we
did it was to involve more than simply
the definitive department of the School
of Management other departments now as
well precisely because this is not it's
in a way it's too important an issue now
to be simply put in that compartment and
you know I think that if we are able to
articulate and describe both what this
interaction means what are its trends
what are potential conclusions or
talking points for policy we will do
something that is very very important
for shaping policy making decision
making political leadership in the 21st
century